you like my shoes oh my goodness look at
those shoes
she's outlandish she's wearing dorothy's
clogs yeah
they look like candy apples plantar
fasciitis
fascinating not it's not contagious and
these
man these feel good on my feet they're
dance goes yeah really kind of like
clogs well is dance co
a name of the company yeah so you're
getting a little something from us
okay i'm hoping that i do well i like
ferraris and
and um by sears
first of all uh i don't know how to
where to begin you have had uh it's it's
so great you do such a fantastic job
you're so funny and you've been doing
such great work and then you're getting
recognized for it which is a nice thing
i mean
between the emmys and the sag golden
globe
i'm just curious how you're handling us
all because you've been thrown into a
world all these big stars
now must be coming up to you saying hi
do you get starstruck
i do i get really star stark i saw
angelina jolie and brad pitt on the red
carpet at um the golden globes and
i was being interviewed and um and i
waved to them they said oh do you and
they waved back and they said do you
know them i said you just
witnessed our meeting right here
angelina was being interviewed and brad
was kind of standing off to the side and
we walked by each other he said hi nice
to meet you and
and and he took my hand and i don't know
i felt like i didn't want to waste his
time so i like pulled it away before he
was done
holding it right here no i felt like i
was taking up too much of his time
and and and he kind of did that and i
just felt really bad so
you don't want that old thing you don't
know where this has been
yeah so i i i wanted i pulled it away
from him and i felt stupid about it but
he was really great he was he's
beautiful yeah yeah
in person he's saying he's uh the nicest
guy you know not like on camera
yeah he looks awful um do you find
yourself uh when you meet someone who's
really famous
uh sometimes important you just stare at
like individual you're just
so famous that there's just this weird
light yeah and you look at what you do
is you see
you see them as you are a real person
you have flaws you have
you know you see them on screen it's
just you don't expect them to have pores
you expect that they're you wax figures
you know
um now uh the glee cast i know was
invited to the white house
yeah this is the level that that you
guys have achieved they have achieved i
was shined
i was not invited to the white house
what no i wasn't wait i thought i heard
the glee cast was invited that must mean
you as well
no i think it's just the kids oh nobody
told me no one told you
you're breaking this news to me right
now
this is awkward this is like wow i was
sure fun at andy's party last night
what andy's playing
[Laughter]
maybe it went to spam yeah well have you
met president obama before i did
i um he came to the gay debates the logo
uh we called him the
of the logo sponsored uh i don't
remember the gay debate it was the pres
well isn't that terrible
they sponsored the presidential debates
in the beginning another republicans
came
but um john edward go hello uh john
edwards and
uh barack obama and hillary clinton were
there and um uh
dennis kucinich and uh i met with him uh
obama uh with a group of people
beforehand you know kind of a meet and
greet and uh he said to me
i'm from chicago he said do i know you
or you look really familiar and i said
well i'm from chicago but
you know i've been there in a while i
don't know if we met there and i i would
remember of course if i met him there
and um so we had a little talk and with
us and then he turned around you went
40 year old virgin our president saw
this 40 year old virgin
i thought that was so cool it's good too
that people i hope people all know that
that's the name of the movie you know
right four-year-old virgin
[Applause]
that's 50-year-old virgin i used to get
that
[Laughter]
you know we were talking about you
mentioned 40 year old virgin and in so
many roles and especially on glee
you do so many things well but you are
so great at being judgmental
with your eyes on that you know i was
thinking about this today it's just i
i just that the judgment that can come
out of those
those look at that right now
[Applause]
you're very easy to intimidate i know i
am you compared
glee to the show the brady bunch and i
was
uh what do you see is the comparison
well the the big comparison we were just
talking about because we were um mr mrs
brady and the brady the real live brady
bunch uh andy was my beloved yeah in the
stage um production
and we were saying how glee is kind of
um the real life brady bunch all over
again we're the parents and we don't get
to go to the white
house basically because we're not the
kids and we're not the ones out doing
the musical numbers we're in the
background watching them
right so also you're also all watching
all the time going ooh
there's lousy it's awful
you know but is it is it first of all
are you a fan of the brady bunch
oh my god it shaped it shaped my psyche
i mean the brady bunch was the thing
you know this that was a home where if a
kid threw a temper tantrum and
ran up the stairs and slammed their door
they would get a gentle knock
from the parent yes come in and sit on
the edge of the bed and say
what's going on that didn't happen in my
house does that happen to your house
no no you threw a temper tantrum and
they were like you know good riddance
yeah stay in your right hand like mine
were which one are you
yeah 35 fret-headed
number 35 is acting up uh i literally
uh sent an email an email in
you were way ahead of yours you were so
far ahead of your time i built a
computer
they said i was crazy i sent a letter to
i i waited for the the um credits the
closing credits of the brady bunch and i
sent a letter to universal studios
casting
and i said i want to be in the brady
bunch do you have a young
like actors program where you know i can
learn how to do this
and they sent me a letter back and it
was an assistant of the casting person
and she
it was a really horrible letter like you
know we don't take unknowns we don't
blah blah blah was probably some
assistant getting themselves off
and um but i took that letter and i put
it in my scrapbook like it was some kind
of victory
yeah you know and they got my name wrong
it said jamie lynch
but i was like oh my gosh i got a you
know a letter from universal studios
even though it was telling me
you know forget your dream and and stay
in dalton illinois
i did not say forget you're no one's
gets a letter that says forget your
dreams
did you have a favorite uh brady bunch
episode was the one that stood out okay
the the the the girls are trying to
build uh their own
we didn't do this episode but they're
trying to build their own clubhouse in
the backyard
the boys had a treehouse so they tried
to end um of course because they're
girls and women they don't know how to
handle
you know saws and hammers and nails and
so they're out there in their little
outfits and
all of a sudden a wall falls in it
almost hits cindy
and so bob so uh mike brady says all
right boys come on
get out there and uh we're gonna we're
gonna do this we're gonna build it we're
gonna show them how it's done and they
go ladies we need lemonade and plenty of
it
and they skedaddled back into the
kitchen and made the lemonade for the
men
i loved it that's a different time who's
mike brady to tell anybody how to build
anything
no that's the crappiest house i've ever
seen exactly
every time they shut a door the whole
thing shakes two bedrooms for six kids
isn't that insane yeah doesn't sound
crazy to me
beats being put up in the attic this
isn't about me
or is it